let me show you what's happening
biden vows to take on gop governors over
schools yeah he didn't just say that he
says get them out of the way right now
local school officials are trying to
keep children safe in a pandemic while
the governor picks a fight with them and
even threatens their salaries or their
jobs talk about bullying in schools
biden said remarks the white house if
they'll not help if these governors
won't help us beat the pandemic i'll use
my power as president to get them out of
the way
i think i think there's like a ninth and
a tenth amendment about that one that
you can't do that joe biden i think i
think it was a few weeks ago uh the
buying administration said that they
were going to fund the schools that get
defunded over mass mandates so the
sanchez was saying we're going to defund
these schools because
uh you're requiring masks that's no good
and then i think the bite administration
said they're going to work to fund those
schools whatever was defunded
governor christie gnome said south
dakota will stand up to defend freedom
joe biden see you in court
all joe biden did with these decrees
was
he it was it was a shot across the bow
to red states
forcing them to assert their positions
in defiance of the federal government
these mandates these threats getting
them out of the way all that stuff
it's it's absurd it's not going to
happen the feds are not going to be able
to go into texas and start going
business to business knocking on doors
and trying to figure things out now
there's taxes
that's where they might get you with the
irs and the currency that's all it comes
down to at the end of the day they can't
they don't have the manpower really and
they wouldn't be able to logistically go
to every single business every door but
what they can do is click a few buttons
on the computer and lock all your bank
accounts i think that's what it pretty
much comes down to we're pretty much
controlled by the us dollar at the end
of the day that's where they have all
that power and all that control over us
because they can click two three buttons
shut everything
it's in fascism yeah do you think that
people in texas south dakota are going
to be like oh no i guess i have to
comply with joe biden
you got wyoming and west virginia the
deepest trump supporting states in the
country you think these places are going
to be like
oh geez i guess i have to comply or do
you think they'll be like screw you yeah
they're going to say screw you and then
their bank accounts are going to get
frozen and then they'll there'll be like
a state uh
issue with the governor whatever is
going to be like to the local you know
local banks that are only in these
certain areas undo it you can't do that
yeah governors will intervene and then
the federal government will probably try
to hit those banks and shut those local
banks now yeah i think there's always
that like who's got the bigger you know
hammer when it comes to that situation
who's got more control over the powers
the businesses will switch to crypto
yeah florida will work up their own
crypto and then the federal government
will make that crypto illegal probably a
felony and then they'll start they'll
withhold tax money to the state and then
you might see other states join in and
you could see definitely that maybe not
civil war but intense civil conflict
dude we're innocent yeah political
conflict no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no we're
we're we're we're in a civil war
you got to find war but i mean fifth
generation all it seems like this is the
fifth generational civil war this is
absolutely um yeah
uh are you familiar with fourth and
fifth generational warfare uh i guess
explain it to me i'm familiar but we'll
start with uh
i assume first generational warfare is
like two people punching each other in
the face and likes you know charging at
each other but in order to gain control
of resources or influence over a city or
a region or a group of people
you can't convince them it goes into
kinetic conflict right physical
confrontation
there's been multiple generations
there's been espionage there's been
cyber warfare we are moving into the era
now beyond all that which is fourth and
fifth generation war warfare fourth
generational warfare is when when it's
not necessarily nation states anymore
it's um people flying different banners
within states and between states
insurgent groups groups like the taliban
groups like al qaeda and groups like
antifa
fifth generation warfare is more in
winning control of resources by
controlling people's minds through
propaganda and information
so in that regard
no no doubt the culture war they call it
right it's been called a cold civil war
over and over again the problem i have
with that phrase cold is that i don't
know there was a dude in portland took
two bullets to the chest
by a guy who was stalking him and had a
communist tattoo on his neck it seems
hot yeah you've got oh it's limited
those are the you'll see limited pockets
of violence and like even the civil war
i mean there was korea or not the civil
war rather the cold war with russia we
had korea which was like a russian
american conflict but in the proxy of a
guy getting sort of but that's like
communist factions supported by a larger
state versus
free enterprise factions supported by
another state that wasn't the u.s
engaging in direct conflict yeah
indirect that's why they call it the
cold war it was a war but it was proxy
now what we're seeing in the united
states isn't cold civil war when you
have people fighting in the streets and
there was a shootout last weekend and
there was a shootout the weekend before
that like
how about a hundred days of violent
rioting in portland with fire bombs
and then when donald trump is like we're
sending some feds together like a
fascist fish it's like dude you're fire
bombing buildings and then you had the
oregon governor i think it was the a.g
sue the federal government over their
attempts to enforce the law now you get
the democrats in the federal government
they're going nuts and now it's the the
so here's what i said
when the blue state was suing you know
donald trump the federal government over
trying to enforce the law and stop the
uh the fire bombings the riots
i was like
this is it
people live in
you know they they view history through
a can through condensed lenses
where you open a book and you read about
the civil war and it's like on this day
this happened on this day this happened
and this day this happened and you're
like wow and you're reading it all
really fast not realizing for the people
living it
yo it was years
like five years the revolutionary war
was 20 years
there were people who were born after
the first conflict in the american
revolution and and
rebel sentiment and then fought in the
war
for two years
they were born into it this stuff went
on for a really really really long time
i also feel like the transfer of
information back then did
definitely took a lot longer than
nowadays right and that's why
it's accelerated now i mean you wanted
to draft a letter it takes you know a
month to have these meetings where they
finally agree the letter then it takes
three months to get to the crown then
the king finally gets a chance to go
through the letter reads it crafts a
response with his advisors and goes to
parliament takes a month three months
later it comes back to the states and
then doesn't even go to every single
state yeah you know so that that could
have taken a year just to have one
message now it's all different but
here's what happens
oregon sues the federal government i
said this is it i mean the federal the
state is rejecting federal authority to
enforce the law on federal property in
their state this is where it begins
now joe biden is trying to enforce
federal decree on red states and they're
going to be doing the same things yo
i love it when people are like i was
talking to russell brand i was on i did
the russell brand podcast recently
and he he brought up he's like you know
you've you've talked quite a bit about
civil war in the past and i was like
yeah that's true and i was like there's
a lot of things you need to understand
about that for one i was right okay and
we just had a shootout last weekend and
the weekend before that and you might
say oh but those are just shootouts
when did we have shootouts five years
ago this is what's up it wasn't
happening but let's break this down i
was like
we had numerous articles from the
atlantic and all these other uh smart
people about the possibility of a civil
war escalating in the united states
especially with donald trump getting
elected you then had a princeton
professor saying i think this is in 2016
we are in a cold civil war this was a
long time ago
and that sentiment emerges and then we
see the battle for berkeley the base
stick man
old women getting explosives thrown at
him i was watching this stuff happen on
the ground in in san jose and berkeley
at these trump rallies and then i was
like yo
people have lost their minds
you don't see a de-escalation when
people want to tit for tat
so i was like i think we're going to see
a civil war and it's not always the
like when you saw those people uh
assault larry elder those are obviously
like la crackheads that are just radical
crackheads just roaming the streets
probably don't leave them yeah but they
have access to political information
yeah being indoctrinated what i was
saying is at that berkeley one uh i
think you were there and i was there at
the same time i noticed
an older crowd who looked normal they
looked like they could have been
teachers waving little trump flags no no
not not that they were picking up rocks
they were on the antifa side they were
picking up rocks and throwing them at
trump supporters and i saw them there
and i was undercover because i wanted to
you know capture what was going on i
told him like hey guys i'm like you
might want to get out of here this is
like nasty because they would just look
like regular people that just probably
walked down the wrong street and
recording it and then i looked back at
the tape and they were picking up rocks
and throwing it at the trump supporters
so where where it was surprised where
did we end up right to have people come
to me and and you know i love these
these you know bread tubers and leftists
being like ah tim pool think civil war
and i'm like well since those
predictions which i've continued to make
we had january 6 where about a thousand
people stormed into the capital building
well i should say a large number of them
stormed through the front gates and were
a lot of people were escorted in by cops
opening the door but they did disrupt
the electoral college vote count now a
lot of trump supporters think that it
was effectively a set up in that police
were standing down that pelosi didn't
get you know a national guard in there
regardless people fought with cops to
get into the capitol building they had
no real plan that's what the fbi report
says but they did shut down the
electoral college vote i'm not here to
overplay this and call it an
insurrection i'm saying yo that's
unprecedented and what did we see around
the same time we had i think it was 48
states involved in a lawsuit
over how the election was handled and
i'm sitting here like yo
i've been telling you people shooting
each other in the streets a dude being
killed then then trump having feds hunt
down the guy who did it and kill him
like yo we are dangerously close to this
stuff falling apart john podesta as
reported by the boston globe said that
if trump wins in 2020 the west coast
should secede from the union a new a
yougov poll data showing that in the
united states five different regions
37.2 percent of the american population
wants their region to secede from the
union a lawsuit between 48 states
contesting the election and to this day
what 80 million or i think it's like
two-thirds of republicans distrusting
the election results thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to see the full show
come back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments and
super chat and we actually will read
your comments on the show don't forget
to like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time